[Music]
this month tens of thousands of africans
europeans
and south americans are converging in
brazil
to create a flash mob of horrible bo
but who needs the heat and humidity the
crowded streets of brazil
teeming with raw sewage when you can get
all that right here
in astoria queens everyone is cheering
their countries
in their favorite sport the rest of the
world calls it football
in america we call it a
waste of time you have to love soccer
the excitement of minimal contact the
thrill of low scoring
if you like watching porn in reverse
this sport
is for you all right
are you pure are you 100 politicians
so really 100 100
okay you know because a lot of people
say they're pure colombian but they're
actually 20 percent baby laxatives
as soon as the teams are done jogging
and warming up
they are going to start the game oh wait
i've just been informed that this is the
game and i've actually been watching
soccer for the past two hours
apologies for any confusion
look at you i can tell by your hat
you're a big fan of looking like an
idiot
it's such a boring game it's two nil i
think i see
soccer as a metaphor for your life
little or no goals
you're drinking in a bar in the middle
of the day
when did you two realize that you didn't
have any gold
still have your mother right i think so
i saw her the other day
she was working the pool
[Applause]
colombia
[Applause]
here
all right there they are the people from
greece i figured i would console them
make them feel better
having had kicked out of them you think
greece still has a chance not to win the
game
just to get the proof for a discover
card
you see it because their economy is in
look at you people now these are real
greek people right here look at this guy
i want to say it's an honor to meet
someone who's humped more sheep than i
have
let's talk about something other than
the game okay let's bond
uh what diner do you work at
and what time do you work out step two
neptune and what diner do you work with
no sure soccer any of you guys played
here as you could tell yeah yeah yeah
who's kidding who i have a feeling
the only thing you've ever tried to kick
is your addiction to halloween candy
there's a lot for the greek to be proud
of a real legacy you guys created the
alphabet
you gave us great words like
unibrow all
came invented by the greek alphabet the
best player
sopranos he's like nobody gives
about him in america but in greece
this guy is like a superstar he's like a
sex
symbol he he could have his choice of
any young boy
it's been a hard run for greece you know
what
drinks for all these guys on mexico
if your last name has fewer than five
syllables
[Music]
[Applause]
i am light blue
i am sky blue sky blue i am
the country that has won two world cups
yeah baby
hell yeah
nothing strikes fear into the hearts of
your enemies like the color of an easter
egg
i've got a jack here we go uruguay i'm a
way we're all gay for uruguay
no look at this look at this flag how
much did you pay ikea to design it
oh baby oh it's on
oh he john [ __ ] your mother
your mother you know what soccer goalie
is a lot like your mother always
slapping balls out of her face
he's really he's got the header he needs
to cross midfield
there he goes there he goes you know
they say that soccer is less exciting
than football
american football but that's really
selling it short don't you think
i mean it's also less exciting than
basketball
and baseball and bowling and
backgammon and miniature golf and
yahtzee
i mean come on let's give soccer it's
due
[Music]
what happened out there what happened in
there tell me what happened
exactly
[Music]
on a high note you don't have to live in
uruguay
a lot of sad people in there what
happened
in uruguay those three to one and you
have a ponytail
and you're seven years old with a
ponytail what happened
did your barber tell you it was a good
idea
why would it's a tragedy
uruguay lost and the 72 year old man has
a ponytail
sir what happened today who told you to
buy a camouflage backpack how did that
come about
what happened after uruguay lost sir
what
what happened today yeah
who told you that shirt would look
attractive on you
what went wrong who told
but sir that doesn't take away the fact
that that shirt is two sizes
how did this happen everyone is asking
today how did he choose to keep wearing
a shirt that accentuates his nipples
there's no explanation people are asking
questions
why are you wearing why is a 60 year old
man wearing soccer mom jeans
how how did it happen everyone here is
[Applause]
stunned
you